how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the mcu and over
the last couple of days you may have
heard a lot of people talk about
a certain leaked trailer coming from
disney that had
a ton of spoilers and reveals in it
there aren't really any spoilers for us
so if you're worried about spoilers you
don't have to be
but it was a pretty revealing trailer as
far as when we can expect to get some
marvel
phase 4 projects including the falcon
and the winter soldier which has
been a big mystery up until now and
black
widow and it looks like black widow is
going to be coming to disney plus
if this trailer ends up being real and
if you haven't seen it i'll show it
right now but first if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you can stay up to
date on all the latest mcu news and so
you can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a zombie hulk
funko pop i'm picking a winner on friday
alright so here's this
leaked trailer
so
[Laughter]
now as far as anybody is concerned this
trailer does
in fact appear to be very legitimate
although there really is no way of
knowing
but as you can see from the footage this
was premiered on a big screen which
means it was probably taken from a
studio this isn't something that would
have aired on television already but it
looks like something that was shown to
maybe some executives or some crew
members that wasn't supposed to be
recorded but ended up getting recorded
it's widely believed that this trailer
is meant for the big meeting that disney
has for their investors on december
10th rumor has it that this is a trailer
that they're going to be showing their
investors for next
year and it accidentally got leaked
because somebody recorded it who wasn't
supposed to
now as far as what this trailer reveals
i'm not sure if you caught it you'd have
to look pretty quickly and it goes by
pretty fast but if you look at the
bottom of the screen
when it goes over the falcon and the
winter soldier it does indeed give us a
release date
and if we freeze the frame and we look
at the very bottom it says
august 13th now if this trailer ends up
being legitimate which it looks like it
is
that means that we're going to be
getting the falcon and the winter
soldier the middle of next year which is
a lot longer than we thought we would
have to wait for the series
however one division is coming out in
the middle of january we can assume that
it's going to last
around a month and a half to two months
depending on how often they release one
of the episodes
so it could go into march which would
mean we would have to wait about six
months in between these marvel disney
plus series however
they did give us a release date for
black widow and if we look at the bottom
there
it says april 16th with premier
access now this is seemingly confirming
that black widow is going to be making
the jump to premier access on disney
plus
this is something that disney
stockholders have been recommending
disney to do and it's something that
recently disney ceo bob chapek has been
hinting at
and then you have warner brothers who
recently announced that wonder woman
1984 is going to be going to hbo max for
streaming now they're also releasing
wonder woman 1984 in theaters as well so
maybe there's hope that black widow
could be released in theaters too
now the release date for black widow is
april which means it fills a pretty
important gap
it fills that six month gap in between
the one division series and the falcon
in the winter soldier series so we have
the one division series starting in the
middle of january going until
probably middle of february beginning of
march and then we have black widow
coming out in april the next month
if it was a normal release and it came
out in theaters they would probably give
that about two months maybe two and a
half three months in the theaters then
they'd wait a couple of months after
that and then
probably release the next project now
it's not going to theaters but perhaps
they'll treat it the same way they'll
give it a couple of months for everybody
to watch it on disney plus as premier
access
which would put us in june and then we
would only have to wait two months until
the falcon and the winter soldier comes
out
and of course the rest of 2021 is going
to be pretty jam-packed
now this trailer also mentions that
there's going to be a disney plus
18 and up now this would obviously be
where they would put films like deadpool
deadpool 2 logan and anything else that
is rated r that they have acquired or
that they have produced and made
themselves
or future films that they're going to
produce and make like deadpool 3.
deadpool 3 is confirmed to be in
pre-production
right now they just hired two new
writers along with ryan reynolds to work
on the script for the movie and since
it's probably not coming out for another
couple of years hopefully by then
theaters are open back up so it'll go to
theaters and then it'll go to disney
pluses 18 and up section and who knows
there's been a lot of rumors recently
about the punisher may be returning and
that could be a rated r film or show and
then of course there's blade which is
expected to
probably be rated r but that's unknown
right now as well
but the point is it looks like disney is
prepared to actually have a
rated r section in this 18 and plus
disney plus
section and again it looks like there
could be an announcement pretty soon on
december
10th when disney has their meeting with
their investors there's supposed to be a
big
announcement so not much longer to wait
hopefully this leaked trailer is real
and we finally have some answers and
hopefully we'll get some official
news from marvel and disney themselves
on december 10th but in the meantime let
me know what you think about this news
be sure to like the video and subscribe
so you stay up to date on all the latest
mcu news and so you can enter my
giveaway
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof